اذهب الى متابعه الوضع الان في شمال غرب
سوريا سرمدا شمال سوريا الثائر مع من هناك
ثائر بكورها منسق عمليات منظمه
ابل في سوريا سيد ثائر صف لنا مشاهداتك
جميعا
فجر اليوم الاثنين
سته اشباط 2023
تعرضت المنطقه منطقه شمال غرب سوريا الى
هزات ارضيه عنيفه
اسفرت عن
انهيار بعض او الكثير من
الابنيه وخصوصا في هذه المنطقه في منطقه
شمال غرب سوريا وخصوصا في مدن ادلب وسرمدا
وحارم وسلقيا
والجسر من ضمن الصور التي شاهدناها من
سرمدا
تحديدا هناك صوره
التقطت لي وكان حي باكمله قد سوي بالارض
في سرمدا
نعم نعم هذا يعود للاسف للبنيه التحتيه
المتضرره خلال سنوات الحرب الطويله الذي
التي عاشتها المنطقه هناك حارات شبه كامله
انهارت على الارض
وما زاد
الجهات المختصه تقوم بانتشال الضحايا الى
الان
الى الان وصل العدد
المصرح عنه من الوفيات حوالي 150 مدني
بالاضافه الى الاعداد الكبيره من الجرحى
الى الان تم الاعلان عن حوالي 400
جريح في المشافي وما زالت عمليات
انتشال الضحايا مستمره الى الان طيب عندما
نتكلم عن زلزال في هذه المناطق نتكلم على
حدث ربما لم يتعود عليه السوريون في هذه
الاماكن هل تم التجاوز الصدمه على الاقل
النفسيه الان
وبدا الوضع يصبح اكثر ربما تنظيما من قبل
الاهالي في البحث عن الناجين او التعامل
مع هذه الكارثه
نعم الحمد لله
بتواجد بعض
المنظمات والجهات التي تساعد حسب
الامكانيات المتوفره لديها الحمد لله
يتم تنظيم الان وانا جالس في هذا المكان
اشعر بهزه ارتداديه الان نعم
الان اشعر بهذا ارتداديه
ارجوك واصل صف لنا
هل هي شديده
نعم هي بصراحه انا اجلس في مكتب في الطابق
الاول
واشعر بالهزه بكل بكل وضوح يعني طيب لا
نريد ان نربطك معنا سلامتك اولا اخرج الان
من هذا المكان ان كان غير امن
ان شاء الله امين
ارتداديه ان شاء الله انتهت
انت لك ان تقدر المغادره الان فغادر ارجوك
شكرا طيب
المنظمات على الارض تقوم ما بوسعه من
بينها منظمه هيومن طيب لنبقى لنبقى في هذه
هل هدات الان سيد ثائر هل هدات الان
هل هذا الهزه هل هدات الان
نعم هدات لهذه
تفضل
لا تقوم المنظمات حسب الامكانيات المتوفره
لديها على الارض
بتنظيم عمليات انتشال
الضحايا من تحت والمصابين من تحت
الانقاض في هذه المنطقه من صوتك
اشعر بان الهزه ما زالت
موجوده هل هذا دقيق
الان اشعر بان كل شيء سابق الحمد لله
الحمد لله الحمد لله طيب